many of european countries face cold and  bitter winters  so what better gift than something to  keep your family and loved ones warm  however being safe is just as important  as being warm  see these heated gloves for example  because of an inadequate manufacturing  the person you give the gift to  could receive an electric shock  the national authorities all over the  european union and the european  commission  work every day to ensure that the gifts  you choose are safe  they order the distributor to recall the  product from end users then  an alert is circulated on common  european platform the safety gate so  that all other member states can follow  suit  give the best gift to your family  choose product safety first have a look  at the au safety get website